One IP, multiple services, different domains, that's what Ingress does.
Every service as a load balancer means a separate IP and a separate cloud bill.
Node port works, but port numbers are ugly.
Ingress is one entry point that routes by hostname and path.
You define an Ingress resource with routing rules.
An Ingress controller, EngineX, Trific, HAProxy, reads those rules and acts on them.
Traffic flows, internet to controller to service to pods.
Route by hostname, api.example.com goes to the API service.
App.example.com goes to the front end.
Route by path, slash api slash routes differently than slash app slash.
TLS termination happens at the controller.
Your services stay plain HTTP internally.
One catch, the Ingress API is frozen.
No new features.
For new projects, look at Gateway API instead.
Run the docs, Kubernetes, Ingress.